in this video i will be reviewing all of
the modern one piece films
finishing off strong world and getting
stuck in and some truly breathtaking
films and stories from film z
all the way to 2019 stampede with the
added bonus of reviewing what appeared
to me to be
the strangest film in one piece's
extensive catalog
the 3d film entitled straw hat chase
which
while looking like a playstation 3 game
was actually
infinitely better than the train wreck i
thought it was going to be
oh and also by the time this video ends
i'll have finished
all of the one-piece films and let me
tell you it wasn't easy and to reward
myself
i'm gonna make this year's last video a
dragon ball one where i review
the morrow arc and so to cap off my one
piece journey for 2020 i present you
with one of my most positive reviews to
date
i'm totally not mark and these are my
first impressions of thoughts on
and review for the surprisingly sound
stupidly effective and
superbly animated modern one-piece film
collection
one piece is the best series i've ever
read in my life first impressions
one thing i want to say from the outset
here is that i understand that these are
films that most one piece fans are
familiar with or have seen
and so because of this i understand that
these are often discussed and compared
and so today i will be sharing with you
all which of these modern films i
thought was the best as well as my
favorite overall
all of these films strong world film z
film gold and stampede were made with
eight year old
directly involved and to be perfectly
frank you can tell as someone that spent
a borderline pathological amount of time
reading the one piece story this year
one thing i've gained and appreciation
for is the sort of magic oda likes to
inject into the worlds and stories he
creates
all of these films are heads and
shoulders above the earlier one-piece
films with the only two that challenge
them being
movie four and movie six in my mind
though none of those feel as distinctly
one piece
as these specific modern films whether
it be strong world or films these fully
integrated and fleshed out characters
film goals superlative world building or
stampedes wall-to-wall action and
character interactions
looking at these four films there's
clearly something here for any breed of
one piece fan
so let's dive into the first of these
oda films by finishing off my review
of strong world strong world is easily
one of the strongest films i'll be
discussing in this video
last week i discussed the first half of
this film and what i loved about it from
its animation to its setup to its
dialogue and cinematography but really
that was just an appetizer because the
first half is effectively all set up if
the first half of this film is water 7
then the second half is ini's lobby
because it is all climax something i was
worried about going into this film was
the significantly longer running time it
boasted
almost half an hour longer than most
films like film 4 and film 6 were
and even longer than the vast majority
of the earlier ones but
it really comes together in a
surprisingly satisfying finish that felt
more one piece than anything i had seen
up until this point helped incredibly by
the outstanding voice work of mayumi
tanaka
this film's second half essentially
explores the aftermath of the beat down
at the hands of this film's fantastic
antagonist
shiki overall this movie deals with nami
being the goal they are there to rescue
her after shiki's declared that she
is his navigator and what's interesting
is that very fight for nami takes place
in the very middle of the film and for
those of you that have followed along
with this series
you'll know that i've mentioned this
midpoint cut off trope in narrative
before this is the writing technique
used to help with pacing and to create
tension moving into the second half of
the film and the final act and so
despite the goal throughout this
two-hour film remaining the exact same
throughout
there's more than enough turbulence to
play with your emotions and to keep you
entertained with the midpoint defeat at
the hands of shiki acting as a perfect
alley-oop for act 3 to slam dunk this
big finish
and boy does it slam dunk this big
finish
with nami leaving behind a message for
her defeated friends to hear once they
come too
reinvigorating us and the crew to storm
shiki's castle in the sky
saving nami and to stop them from
destroying the east blue and boy
do they make good on that promise as i
mentioned the second half of this film
despite a few moments here and there
showing nami making her moves to free
herself
largely is centered around the incoming
conflict between this monstrous sheiki
and the lovable straw hat crew and one
thing i think this movie gets right
more than any other is the one piece
walk
and something i'd like to share with you
all is that
prior to reading through one piece i had
never experienced a hero walk on the
scale
of what aichiro oda offers in his story
here and that's not because
any other film or anime i watched lacked
them not even close there were tons that
included hero walks but within this film
as luffy and the straw hats marched
their way into the hq of shiki
bathing in a white light and coming off
as massively intimidating to those
around them it helps to reaffirm this
nostalgic side of a viewer
because we all know where all of these
oddball and outcast characters
are from and where their strengths and
weaknesses lie we've seen them go from
being
jokes that no one recognizes to being
notorious around the world and that's a
feeling for me at least
that is unique to one piece oftentimes
anime and film will create these hero
walks with really
little behind it simply because they
think it looks cool and you know it does
it does the job
on a surface level but what one piece
however does is this hero walk with
enough substance to make you tearfully
look on
like a proud mother because you've seen
them all grow up it's a ridiculously
satisfying feeling
simply because you get the satisfying
cool walk that aesthetically looks great
but it has this visceral substance that
one piece so
fervently offers time and time again and
the battle that ensues here after the
dramatic walk is equally fantastic
with the subordinates of shiki having
already been characterized in a way that
isn't just a brooding tough guy
we have an effeminate gorilla and a blue
mime whose shoes make fat sounds
whenever he takes a step
[Music]
once again similar to shiki these guys
offer the straw hats interesting
scenarios because
of the characterization they've been
granted by oda and what's more is this
film from top to bottom has been
gorgeous
with terrific animation both from an
action standpoint comedic standpoint and
a character acting standpoint
zoro and sanji specifically get a lot of
opportunity when it comes to comedic and
action moments which is another amazing
part of why i love these characters the
fact that sanji can jump from a comedic
approach to a breakneck action in the
blink of an eye is a testament to just
what a fantastic character he is
and even though zoro has a much more
stoic onenote persona
that very aspect of his personality is
utilized for comedic effect quite often
in the series too and
these fight scenes they participate in
are fantastic but
the fight that receives the most love
and attention comes from luffy versus
shiki i really like how luffy is
motivated by nami's message even more
than he normally would be taking
specific issue with her
not believing in him and trusting him
that very rage and anger
that luffy is feeling comes through in
this film in a massive
and i mean emphasis on massive
with luffy in conjunction with the storm
brewing in the sky
utilize the fact electricity can't hurt
him and lands a massive thundercharge
kick onto shiki that ultimately takes
him out
of the entire film the storyboard sets
up this to look fittingly massive
and intimidating truly an attack worthy
of the king of the pirates
overall i honestly loved this film it's
got
action but doesn't use it as a crutch
has a specific story it wants to tell
does it brilliantly has a great set of
antagonists and has such a wonderful
sense of humor with an
atmosphere that is distinctly one piece
specifically at the end when the rest of
nami's message is revealed
she never gave up hope she always
believed in them to rescue her
needless to say i highly recommend
everyone check out this movie
straw hat chase when i was composing
this list of films i had to watch and
review for these videos
the 2011 less than half an hour long 3d
film entitled straw hat chase
was a piece of media i was particularly
excited to watch
specifically because i thought it was
going to be awful to an almost absurd
degree
weird 3d models less than half an hour
long to tell a story in a title that
reads as though it comes from a
children's book
straw hat chase was a venture i was
certain would give me a chance to flex
my inner critic much more
than i had in the past with this series
there's a butt coming but
i was totally wrong totally unlike the
artistically bankrupt
underproduced corporate sludge i was
expecting this to be
straw hat chase was brimming with
character made
full use of its 3d nature with dare i
said
gorgeous tracking shots and what's more
is it has a perfectly nice story that
while not big in scope
leans into the emotional aspects of one
piece instead which
offers it much more impact than anything
like this
had any right to have essentially the
story covers the antics of a particular
pooch acting on behalf of his dying
master to retrieve
luffy's straw hat thinking it to be an
impossible mission he thought it should
keep his beloved pet busy while he
himself
dies of old age it's a sad angle to
tackle the story from but it's uplifted
again as we see the humor that ensues
when luffy himself becomes
more and more frantic looking everywhere
for his prized possession
throughout the short run time of this
film the marines become involved there's
a massive chase some surprisingly fun
action with humor and an emotional core
the likes of which i wasn't even
remotely expecting i can't believe i'm
saying this but
straw hat chase is a film you should
totally check out it's only like
25 minutes so it's not a big time sink
either the next and final three films
filmsy film gold and stampede are movies
i watched all on the same day i enjoyed
all of them
though each for very different reasons
with one i enjoyed less than the other
two
so let's take a look let's jump in with
film z
the very first thing that stood out to
me in film z was its villain
normally visuals catch my attention
first but at this point in history one
piece is making more money than the
monopoly man and thus
i expect all these modern films to look
spectacular sporting a masterful
implementation of 2d practices with some
3d thrown in to seamlessly enhance
background special effects and in some
cases
character art and this film does all of
that as i expected to a very high
standard however what did interest me
was
its exploration into the tragic
backstory of a disillusioned estranged
one-time naval admiral
zee is introduced to us as this
determined no-nonsense brute with a
moral outlook he adheres to to an almost
pathological extent though that doesn't
mean we don't appreciate his struggles
and point of view through flashbacks
character interactions and his own
exposition
we come to learn his origin and the
events that made him the cool killer he
is today
what i found particularly interesting
about him however is that while he
commands the screen with the intent of a
typical brooding tough guy he very
clearly has
physical limitations made evident
through his inhaler his arm
and his age reinforcing the notion that
he is a grizzled old man that could very
well be past the days where he should be
fighting but this old man views his
goals as worthy of dying for
which is a really intense villain to
have our light-hearted but determined
crew to fight against
specifically because this z guy right
here wants to rid the world of
pirates with their very first ever
interaction coloring this contradiction
and complexity of the story
really well luffy and the straw hats are
pirates pirates that save zee's life
as they discover him as he lies
motionless in the sea below initially
grateful for this rescue as soon as he
learns who they
are a massive fight breaks out with some
terrific animation incorporating his
crew
and the straw hats in battle on top of
there being a cool factor to a lot of
these initial interactions there's a
healthy emphasis on the comedy in these
exchanges too with a specific highlight
being the grass knots tying everyone up
this particular battle is interesting
too as robin nami brook and chopper all
fall victim to the evil fruits power of
one of his subordinates
that makes everyone 12 years younger
it's a cool what-if scenario and it's
neat getting to see all of these
characters either as children or in
robin's case
as an 18 year old girl and of course
brooke who
hasn't changed at all
the plant itself doesn't have as many
moving parts as something like strong
world had
effectively we get introduced to the
villain he meets and scuffles with the
straw hats he inflicts damage they look
for more information about him so they
can find him again
they find him again he then wins the
second fight and causes even more damage
this time taking luffy's hat and then
the third and final time they clash
luffy and his crew win the day however
breaking down this film like that does a
disservice to what this film is focusing
on
and what the film is trying to achieve
while not being complex on a plot level
the themes and character moments and
exchanges explored and expressed in this
film are easily its strongest suit and
perhaps the strongest in all of these
films
while i personally found cheeky to be a
more enjoyable character to watch luffy
go toe to toe with that's just the
taste thing and z offers luffy an
extremely different but equally if not
more complex and interesting dynamic you
might have noticed at this point that
i've spoken at length about z
the antagonist of this film and that's
with good reason
he is in my opinion the best part of
this movie the action
is great and i love the straw hats but
the tragic philosophy and damage
disillusionment
z brings to the table painting every
part as a traitor to humanity and in
dire need of an exterminator is
something that luffy
pardoned the pun always bounces well off
of in both
a dialogue and action situation z is a
tormented and depressed character that
by the end i was
massively sympathetic for and through a
specific flashback as well as through
garp's own monologue we learn about his
past and how he slowly over time became
more and more disillusioned as a result
he's clearly a man that has had a life
wrought with struggle tragedy and loss
driven seemingly at this point only by
the sole desire to see
all pirates fall his body is giving up
on him his arm is missing he uses an
inhaler and he clearly is suppressing
his emotions through drinking
heck he has a subordinate that could
very easily return him to his youth
but he doesn't want to he doesn't want
to live
he just wants to see this mission he has
in his head through to the end and
that's harrowing it's a sad set of
circumstances with sympathy eventually
coming from both sides
the pirates and the navy's higher-ups
what's more is that this film does a
fantastic job at integrating
pre-existing characters in garp and
other very important naval hq higher-ups
as they comment on past events relevant
to the film
as well as the man they grew up with
inzy in addition to that the world
building
isn't a large focus in most of the story
taking place on a small island but we
also get to see water 7's train in
operation which is always cool
and overall i can totally see how this
is so many people's favorite one piece
film to date
it's got perhaps the most complex and
interesting villain of one piece movie
has had thus far
some brilliant dynamics between
characters some fun comedy and powers on
display
and the stakes are on a fittingly large
scale causing admirals of the navy to
get involved even former admirals like
okigi
in other words this film it feels like a
big deal through and through from an
action standpoint things are pretty much
as you'd expect
top tier specifically in the final act
zoro luffy and sanju's fight scenes
incorporate 3d effects and character
models seamlessly into action creating
fight scenes that are
honestly breathtaking some of the very
best in the series i think
and this is coming from someone that
hates 3d animation in his anime usually
but i think it worked in this film
because
it's clear that it's not being used as a
crotch they are doing everything they
normally would do with
bonkers traditional animation while
using the 3dfx to elevate it further and
i think that's a massive distinction
that needs to be made but with that said
it brings me to the ending of this film
music isn't necessarily something i feel
comfortable speaking on just yet because
it's not really my forte but the
implementation of music in this film is
so emotionally rich
it simply begged me to give it a shot
there's this sailor song
that's sung by okiji and hummed
throughout this film and at the end it
acts as zee's song
he says goodbye with he's a broken man
that's just too far gone
and having played a large role in the
lives of the admirals today he decides
to give them one last
training session all the while the song
plays in the background this track
effectively acts as the light motif of
zee
and his struggles with him coming full
circle now accepting his fate
it's a tragically sad scene and of all
of the films
is one of the few that brought me to
tears overall one piece film z is a
powerful
action-packed and emotionally rich
drama-filled ride
that is fun but also forces you to
contend with darker subject matters
it is without question a movie that i
highly recommend anyone to check
out film gold one piece film gold is a
strange film but not in a bad way i
thought it was really interesting
watching one piece give their own
interpretation on a more
american culture specifically las vegas
and it's a pretty fun and engaging
setting to boot in fact i'd go as far as
to say that
in the case of environment and
establishing its world this film does it
better than any other film in the one
piece series
that and there are so many characters in
this movie that speak
random pieces of english it's honestly
pretty funny with that said this film
also boasted a perfect introduction
completely capturing the vibe of its
story the environment
and the characters involved and how
through song
the big bad of this film goes full
disney villain and complete with a full
song and dance number
gets across his motivations and
personality superbly and with the straw
hats approaching they get doused in a
golden snow like flake substance
and that's when we see it the most
massive ship in the entire series
perhaps even bigger than thriller park
a golden shining ship clearly taking
inspiration from gambling capitals of
the world
like las vegas as i said as mentioned
prior also the world building and
establishment of the world has to be the
best out of the series of films for me
we see cars and how they work
we see how people live their buildings
the political and sociological
structures
and the big boat has a golf course
traditionally speaking the story itself
is fairly standard at least when it
comes to these films
the gang go to a place the place appears
to be fine until something bad happens
and then luffy punches someone really
hard to fix it that's
essentially this film but there's a
little more going on
than just that too the art direction
once again is really fun and the straw
hats get different costume changes with
new spiffy outfits
luffy be rocking that shirt it also
makes great use of the 3d effects in
swooping wood shots to emphasize how
massive the area truly is
however once on the boat cracks begin to
form in the surface of this seemingly
happy society as street urchins start
begging for money and pushing their
products onto the straw hat crew this is
primarily the theme of this film and i'm
not sure i'd go as far as to say that
this film
is anti-capitalist i mean nami is still
a character that wants money more than
life itself though i do think a very
pronounced aspect of the story deals
with how those in power can squash the
aspirations and opportunities of others
if they lack the resources with that
very character obsessed with money being
the main antagonist himself
i mean he sang about that very aspect of
himself at the beginning
he really does help to reinforce the
themes of this film and
really that's what i enjoyed about it
how the themes dictated the plot and
this in part is largely what makes the
villain in this film
so engaging everything that makes him
who he is from his philosophy to his
morals it all
dictates everything in the plot and
everything about what makes this ship
and in effect the world look the way it
does
he has the power to control and
manipulate gold and because the entire
boat is essentially
casted in gold the ship is effectively
completely under his control
and really the straw hats are none the
wiser to the circumstances they are
walking into until
they end up losing their money in one
big fell swoop before being cast
into slavery you see what's interesting
here is that has a subordinate that can
literally take the luck away from anyone
and thus in
effect riggs luffy's bet to lose and
really once they get caught up in the
enslavement the battles start to get the
ball rolling onto the third act
of these fights by far and away my
favorite was luffy versus
this thing is given time to breathe and
boy does it go on for a while
and i mean that in a good way the way
this storyboard powerfully frames
as this massive imposing figure with
luffy looking on
tiny as he is no doubt facing a massive
task in overcoming these insurmountable
odds
all in an effort to liberate the people
of this massive ship
there's some really nice strategy in
play too as luffy uses sea water to
cover the top of the ship
effectively making use of the devil
fruit's adverseness to sea water in an
effort to loosen the grip
as on his ship and boy does this work
it's great
effectively removing the gaudy golden
facade leaving behind a grey and
decrepit husk beneath
everything about the villain is surface
level and despite us getting context for
how he came to be who he was
it's too little too late and wham bam
thank you ma'am
luffy utilizes gear 4 crushes this
golden golem
liberating the ship and freeing everyone
overall i
actually like this film way more than i
expected to despite not having seen any
of these films prior
i did go in with expectations due to the
conversation surrounding them online
i knew film z was going to be amazing
but the impression i got from the
community on this one
was that it was supposed to be mediocre
but i actually ended up really enjoying
it i found it to be a solid story
phenomenally well animated utilizing
great 3d effects and the themes
really carried a ton of the weight in
this feature in addition to that the
film
also boasts what i believe to be the
best setting for one of these films to
be set in i mean i swear if
i see another wasteland fight on a
random island i'm gonna pull my hair out
so that was fun too all in all i totally
recommend
checking this film out stampede stampede
is a 2019 film that is effectively
wall-to-wall nostalgia
and fan servers which is both a great
and a bad
thing of all the films i've seen
visually this film sports
my favorite art style the thicker lines
look phenomenal
personally i've always hated those thin
digital lines so many animated shows
have today
so this was a welcome change in addition
to that the animation in this film is
brilliant also
for the most part like most of these
films the premise is revealed to us
almost
immediately with the straw hats
announcing that they are on their way to
a pirate fest
to participate in a treasure hunt they
arrive in the town and not even 10
minutes into the film
as buggy the clown comes crashing into
the picture we begin to get a sense that
this film will try to cram as many
characters from new and old one piece
into it as it possibly can
some are incredibly welcome like buggy
and law but others like the foxy pirates
and king wapple
are there for essentially no other
reason than for to make the movie
say hey guys look reference but perhaps
that's being unfair this is honestly way
more fun than it is annoying so
i'll let it slide the pacing of this
film too is honestly quite good
specifically towards the first half
as there really isn't a dull moment to
be seen between reintroductions and
cameos from old characters to breakneck
races and
capital a action there's more fighting
in this movie than the actual movie and
i mean that in a good way the story
itself is probably the most simple i've
seen
in a long while which isn't by default a
bad thing but what's more is that this
film
also incorporates the worst antagonist
of these modern one-piece films in my
opinion this gentleman
initially released and discovered in
impel down by blackbeard
is effectively everything i mentioned
that i dislike about the prior older
films he doesn't provide luffy or
anyone really with much of anything to
converse with he's got
virtually no personality and his
backstory isn't revealed until the movie
is almost over
apart from being a massively powerful
individual he doesn't really offer the
story much
or at least not that i saw and with the
story being extremely simple in that
they arrive on an island they
encounter the bad guy and now have to
defeat him the fact that he doesn't have
much
to him really made the film feel less
important than it should have
considering how much it has going
for it despite seeing footage of roger
and other massively important
individuals within the one piece world
present in this feature
the story felt small and this antagonist
felt virtually
unimportant even though from a
historical standpoint and plot level he
is super important but by far in a way
the worst aspect of this film comes in
the form of
the facade he assumes during the final
fight with all the wonderful cgi used in
all of these films including this one
that i praised
this 3d model is one of the worst i've
seen
and with it being such a predominant
part of this film i thought they could
have done a much better job one piece
movie four from 2003 had better 3d
effects
and this stampede film is from 2019. i
don't see the excuse here
but that's pretty much everything i
dislike about this movie right off the
bat so let's talk about what i liked
because
there's honestly plenty about it that i
loved as mentioned prior there's a lot
of fighting in this film like
people gave dragon ball super broly a
really hard time for being almost
half fighting but i swear this film is
like 80
fighting personally i was never one of
those people that belittle broly for
having too much fighting and i won't be
one here in this film either because the
action is honestly some of the best in
the series with some gorgeous colors and
of course storyboarding and on top of
that
everyone fights in this film usopp sanji
robin
zorro has some incredible moments nami
brook chopper
got fujitora smoker various admirals
luchi crocodile
and even sabo in all of his fiery glory
this is really a greatest hits
of one piece if ever i did see one
however my favorite aspect of this film
comes in the form of the treasure hunt
incentive and more specifically the
treasure itself
an eternal pose that leads to none other
than the end of the grand line
laugh tale home of the fabled one-piece
treasure owned once by
gold d roger
now if that's not a prize you want i
don't know what is and
well the conflict here comes obviously
from the big bad but
also everyone including the navy
threatening to blow up the island
in order to get the ultimate prize that
eternal pose
with so many factions crews and naval
personnel fighting in this film it
honestly gave me end-game vibes with how
many callbacks there were and how
many unlikely team-ups we got to see and
once luffy does win the day
and finally gets his hand on the
internal pose leading to his dream
i might add in an effort to stop the
fighting he crushes the log pose and
puts an
end to all of it citing that since he is
going to be the king of the pirates
he doesn't need this eternal pose that
he will find it
on his own and as he says this boa
hancock swoons in the corner
i love that rationale with luffy
prioritizing the safety of others while
also highlighting his determination to
get to the end of his own dreams on his
own
terms it reinforces his character and
was one of if not the best character
moments in the entire film
with his only competition in this
specific department coming in the form
of usopp
in this movie usopp is awesome i might
have liked it so much because
it's been a while since i've seen usopp
do much of anything within wano
however in this film he does and really
it's thanks to him that the big bad is
actually taken down in the end amazingly
on top of usop's laments during this
film over how he felt as though he
wasn't strong enough to contribute
he once again finds solace in helping
from afar as a sniper
reinforcing the themes of friendship
alongside the theme we are
luffy deals the final low leading to
chillers running down my spine
as well as a tear filling my eye but
perhaps the most interesting part of the
film comes at the very very
end when we're greeted by a flashback to
gold d roger talking about the one piece
treasure citing
he was too early what does that mean
the highs of this film surpass many of
the other films for me but unlike the
other films in this video specifically
it feels less like a story but more like
a spectacle and i personally really
enjoyed that part but
the villain just really didn't do it for
me with that said if someone were to
tell me that this was their favorite
film
i could see why there's a lot to like
but with that said
it's time to rank these films of the
five films i've discussed today my
favorite is perhaps a toss-up between
strong world and film z
though i think personally i had more fun
watching strong world as it had a more
complicated story that i could sink my
teeth
into with that said i think film z was
the most
emotionally powerful of these films so i
guess it all depends on how i'm feeling
currently it's strong world but that
could very easily change by the day
regarding the others i didn't really
dislike any of these films
i just disliked some more than others
and that one that i disliked more than
the others was
perhaps stampede i'd personally still
rank it way higher than the other films
if i were to take what i liked out
and remove the bad parts like the boring
villain but if i'm being fair i
personally enjoyed film gold more on a
first
watch however not by much stampede
offered significantly higher highs than
film gold did
so once again if you were to ask me
which my favorite between the two were
on another day it could very easily
result in a different answer but for now
i preferred film gold to stampede and
finally given that straw hat chase
isn't a feature film by definition it's
way too short i'm gonna put it in a
separate category into and of itself
i think that's fair plus i really
enjoyed it with that said that concludes
my review of the one piece films i hope
you had fun
and i can't wait to review the moral arc
of dragon ball super at the end of the
month
thank you for joining me on this journey
and now it's time for the one piece
specials
wish me luck i've been told not mark i
love you all
and thank you so much for watching
bye